may it be allowed to send to you this
little writing of mine in order that the
entry of the tatas and the very great
destruction and harm of the Christian
people may stand clearly before you
would ship may you read it carefully for
indeed you will find in it much that
happened before my own eyes and many
other things that I experienced myself
but should you at times finding it such
matters that may appear horrendous and
terrible to the human mind you should
not be astonished at me the writer all
the events but give thanks to the King
of Kings who forgetful of his Mercy did
not spare his oppressed people but
wetted his sword as the lightning
against them I'm not telling this
without purpose because he who should
fall into the hands of the tatas it were
better for him not to have been born and
I say this as one who has known it I was
among them for a time and a half and
death would have been a Solace for life
it was but a torture
in the year of the Lord's Incarnation
1242 it happened that kutan King of the
humans sent solemn envoys to the king
with the message that he had fought the
Tartus for many years and twice defeated
them but the third time as he was
unprepared they suddenly broke into his
land and so being unable to have an army
he was forced to turn his back to the
cursed tatus they devastated most of his
land by force and killed his people
after the passing of one year of the
Lord news came that the tartars were
devastating the confines of Hungary
adjacent to ruse when this was announced
all across Hungary the hungarians amidst
their exceeding hilarities did not
believe it and maintained that they had
often heard such things about the tatas
and always found out they meant nothing
said that many things are reborn that
have fallen before about the middle of
Lent one of the palatine's men arrived
post haste to the king and reported in
the name of the counter Palatine that
the tartars had reached the Russian gate
and were destroying the Border obstacles
the King was still incredulous but on
the fourth day the Palatine himself
arrived having ridden night and day and
reported that in early March on the 12th
he had engaged them at the gate almost
all his men had been cruelly killed by
arrows and swords he'd escaped with a
few and come to report what had happened
the king although quite astounded by the
bad news released his archbishops
Bishops and others his ispens and Barons
firmly and strictly ordering them to
gather their troops and returned to him
as soon as possible not losing time as
urgent necessity and evident need
demanded
the enormous Mongol attacks on Japan in
the 13th century were the largest
seaborne Invasion fleets in history
until the Normandy Landings some 700
years later and so our sponsor today is
the visceral World War II multiplayer
shooter enlisted a great choice for
historically accurate Dynamic action and
a game where you get a first person view
of D-Day itself it's free and available
to play on PC Xbox series SX and PS4 and
5 with cross-platform support you can
battle in distinct historical campaigns
such as Normandy and the battle for
Moscow with several more already being
worked on for me I was most impressed
that the uniforms vehicles and even
locations have been crafted with
historical authenticity in mind join me
in enlisted and watch me embarrass
myself again and again in suitably
realistic ways follow the link in the
description to get the game as well as
three days of Premium Time and several
orders for troops and weapons thanks to
enlisted for supporting history content
on YouTube
the city of Aradia was very famous in
Hungary therefore many Nobles ladies and
peasant women had gathered there even
though the bishop had left with some of
the Cannons I stayed there with the
remaining people who had the castle
repaired with a strong wall so that we
could find Refuge there should we be
unable to defend the city
but when one day the tartars suddenly
arrived in my situation in the city was
precarious I did not want to go to the
castle but ran away into the forest and
hid there as long as I could they
however suddenly took the city and
burned down most of it and left nothing
outside the walls of the castle having
collected the booty they killed men and
women commoners and Nobles alike on the
streets houses and Fields
they pardoned neither sex nor age that
done they suddenly retreated gathered up
everything in the retreat unsettled five
miles from the castle they didn't return
for days and those in the castle thought
they had left because of the strength of
the castle when the tartars did not come
to the castle for several days and
everyone thought that they had
completely withdrawn from there many of
the Warriors and others who were in The
Castle confident that they had withdrawn
left the castle and moved together into
the houses that still remained outside
of it then one day a dawn the Tartus
whose whereabouts they could not know
rushed upon them and killed those who
did not manage to flee to the castle
they immediately surrounded the
fortification set up seven Siege engines
across from the new wall and bombarded
it ceaselessly with stones day and night
until the new wall collapsed totally
They seized the Warriors cannons and
others who had not been killed by The
Sword in the attack the late these
damsels and Noble girls tried to escape
into the cathedral but because they
could not easily enter the cathedral
they set fire to it and burnt the church
together with the women and whatever
there was in the church
in other churches they perpetrated such
crimes that it is better to keep silent
as people get ideas for most evil Deeds
then they ruthlessly beheaded the Nobles
citizens soldiers and canons on a field
outside the city they violated the
Saints Graves trampled upon the relics
with their sinful feet smashed to Pieces
the sensors crosses golden chalices and
vessels and whatever else was designed
for the service of the altar they
dragged men and women alike into the
churches and shamefully mistreated and
then killed them there after they had
destroyed everything they left the place
empty people hiding in the nearby
forests came back to find some food and
while they were searching among the
stones and the bodies the tatas suddenly
returned and of those living whom they
found there none was Left Alive
and this Slaughter was repeated day
after day
the king of kings and Lord of the
tartars who entered Hungary was called
by the name of Batu having entirely and
single-mindedly destroyed ruse and
kumania they decided to occupy Hungary
when the king marched out from the city
of pescht as I mentioned and moved with
a great number of armed men against the
tatars they stopped burning Villages
quickly assembled and retreated by the
way they had come meanwhile the king
encouraged his men to prepare manfully
for battle and personally handed out
many flags among the Great Men the
hungarians though trusting their number
made fun of all this and owing to the
mat as discussed above had neither mind
nor spirit for fighting they thought
that any such Calamity would only hit
some in particular and not all in
general
but not now the present was no way like
the past
the tartars found a Ford far from the
Army and crossed overnight adorned they
surrounded the entire Royal Army and
started shooting arrows like a hail
storm the hungarians being both
disconcerted and outwitted by their ruse
armed and mounted their horses but the
soldiers could not find their commanders
the commanders their men and when they
set out to battle they marched frankly
and slackly arrows were shot into the
air so densely that they almost covered
the Warriors in Shadow and flew like
locusts and grasshoppers that move in
swarms unable to resist the shower of
arrows they returned to the camp
there the King was unable to set up
battle Lines no message not a word was
passed among them while the king thought
they were going into battle they were
escaping rather than going to fight the
slaughter among those both fleeing on
the broad road towards pesht and those
who stayed with the Army were so
enormous so many thousand men perished
that one could not estimate it nor can
one very well trust reports as the loss
was so huge thank you
no mortal man may have certain knowledge
of the major and lesser Layman who
drowned in the marshes and rivers were
consumed by fire or perished by the
sword
horses ran around in the fields and
Groves with saddle and bridle but
without Riders and was so panicked by
the noise that they seem to have gone
mad their naying sounded like groaning
or crying
the tatas were at that time concerned
only with slaying people and seemed to
care little for loot
we who stayed in the forest among the
Border obstacles took flight at night
towards damashta a large German Village
on the Krish River but the Germans did
not let us cross the bridge instead many
of them insisted that we had to defend
their fortified City together with them
which didn't please us at all so we
turned off to an island which was being
well fortified since I dared not go on I
stayed with them when I realized that
this place was so well fortified I liked
it and I stayed there when I'd been
there for a few days with my servants
how Scouts reported that the tartars
were approaching I hired a guard and a
servant each of us heading three horses
and hastened by night to the city of
trinad on the muresh river eight miles
from the island as we were riding all
night as fast as our horses could carry
us Adorn we reached chanad but a day
before it too had been taken and
destroyed by the tatas who had entered
Hungary from the other side
the whole region was occupied with left
our horses in some huts and hid for the
day in some pits and at nightfall we
crept back in amidst the tatas with
great difficulty and fear to the old
place and entered the island eyes
downcast and ashamed while we were in
such danger my servants who were
guarding the horses outside and some
others who were with me fled from the
island with all my money and my clothing
the tartars caught them in flight and
cut them down while I remained with one
servant and almost naked on the island
not much later the news came that the
Tartus had taken a dawn that said
tamashta the village of the Germans and
All Those whom they did not keep alive
were beheaded by the sword with
horrendous cruelty hearing this my hair
stood on end my body shivered with fear
my tongue stuttered miserably for I saw
that the inevitable moment of dreadful
death was menacing me I also saw human
beings when earnestly expecting death
unable to grab weapons raise their arms
move their steps to places of safety or
survey the land with their eyes I saw
people half dead of fear
I called the people of the island
together so that we would be better
protected then I left together with the
people and taking two children the sons
of the headman my host and the only
servant I still had I hid among the
Border obstacles pretending to go
further into the forest
sent word to the father of the children
that I was afraid to return to the
island thinking that if I kept and hid
his sons he would send over Necessities
to us but when at the break of dawn the
rituals were sent the tartars suddenly
arrived and surrounded the island they
gave out that they would attack the
island from the water thus the Island's
people were tricked into defending it
from that side the tatas however stormed
the unguarded gates on the other side
seized them and took the island without
any of us having shot an arrow or
engaging with them on Horseback or on
foot Not only was it horrible to see how
many great crimes and what cruel Deeds
they perpetrated there but even to hear
it would make people recoil in Terror
they took all the booty and left only
the bodies when very many people who had
hidden after three days thought the
tartars had withdrawn they returned to
the island to find food and the tartars
who were concealed there called them and
only very few escaped
when hunger and thirst pained me too
much I too was forced to go to the
island at night overturning remains to
look for hidden flower or meat or some
other food stuff whatever I could find I
took it deep into the forest
after 10 or 20 days I again went to the
island behold what grief there was what
stench What Fear I think no one however
much he imagines all types of suffering
would not shudder at this suffering I
had to seek caves excavate pits or find
Hollow trees to have shelter while the
tatas like hounds tracking rabbits and
boars rushed through the thick of the
thorn bushes the Shadows of the Groves
the depths of the waters and the Heart
of the Wasteland they searched the
forests for a month or more and since
they could not slay everyone there they
invented a new trick as follows
they captured some who were hiding in
the forest and sent them out with the
message that whoever gave himself up to
their trust before a set deadline would
be allowed to return home safely because
the people were already dying for lack
of food they fully believed their word
and so all who were there returned to
their homes and since these forests are
vast and innumerable people hid there
the land in an area of three days walk
came to be repopulated and every village
chose its king from among the tatas at
its will
after this all brought in the crops as
it was Harvest time including the hay
and the straw and everything else to be
stored many of the tatas who were there
with us looked at all this and enjoyed
and were delighted that fathers redeemed
their lives through their daughters
husbands through their wives Brothers
through their pretty sisters kept for
their pleasure they said bailiffs over
the people in order to render Justice
and Supply them with useful horses
animals weapons presents and clothing so
he had peace quotes of Law and everyone
obtained Justice the most beautiful
girls were sent to them and those who
procured them received sheep oxen or
horses I often went there to find out if
there was any way of getting free all
the bailiffs gave the order that from
certain Villages the men women and
children should appear before them with
gifts
we were quite frightened by this news
for we did not know its reason therefore
I chose to go to the Army rather than
stay in the village in such uncertainty
the bailiffs went to receive the gifts
and after they had received them they
led the bearers of the gifts into a
valley and killed them there after
terribly despoiling them
another part of their army turned
towards estergum but only a few went
that far they mostly settled some
distances away and prepared some 30
Siege engines those of esterigum had
meanwhile fortified themselves with
moats walls and wooden Towers the
commoners knights Nobles and ladies who
gathered in that remarkable Fortress was
so self-confident that they thought they
could resist the whole world but the
hungarians and the French and the
Lombards who were like Lords of the city
realized that they could not hold out so
they set fire to the suburbs and the
wooden houses of which there were many
all the way to the stone Palace in the
houses they burned immense amounts of
dyed clothes and garments slaughtered
the horses buried gold and silver and
hid whatsoever Goods they had before
retiring to the Palaces to defend
themselves when the tartars found out
that all by which they wanted to get
rich had been burnt they became very
angry and swiftly closed off the city
with wooden Palisades so that whoever
tried to escape would run into the
throat of the sword having taken them
swiftly I believe to tell the truth that
no more than 15 people were not killed
in or outside the city
they who would you to be captured and
killed the better ladies dressed as
beautifully as they could gathered in
one of the Palaces and appealed for an
audience with the grand Prince all about
300 of them were LED out of the city to
The Prince and asked for the gift of
being Left Alive under his rule
he however in his anger for not having
won any booty ordered them to be robbed
and beheaded
and that was done right away
they held the country both Beyond and on
this side of the Danube but the part on
this side of the Danube was not as much
destroyed because they did not encamp
here but only wasted all they found when
marching through thus moving back slowly
we reached Transylvania where many
people who had survived and several
castles were what more with the
exception of a few castles they occupied
the whole country as they passed through
they left the country desolate and empty
as I had no hope of survival and a
bitter and cruel death was already
waiting at the door I thought it were
better to die here than be tortured by
this steady stings of fear therefore I
left the highway as if following the
cool of Nature and rushed towards the
dense forest with my only servant and
hid in the hollow of a creek covering
myself with leaves and branches my
servant hid further away so that the
chance detection of the one should not
cause the unhappy capture of the other
were they thus for two full days as in
Graves not raising our head and heard
the terrible voices of those who
following the footprints of urine beasts
past close by in the forest and often
shouted after the prisoners who were in
hiding
and when we could no more repress in the
Deep Silence of our hearts the very just
demands of hunger we lifted our heads
and began to crawl like snakes using
arms and legs we mournfully wept and
groaned that it would have been easier
to Die By The Sword than that the bond
of our Limbs and the unity of body and
soul fall apart through starvation
while we were exchanging such words of
consolation a man appeared and as soon
as we set our eyes on him we took to
fearful flight and did not turn our
sight away to see whether he was gaining
or falling behind us in Flight we began
to walk across the waist and abandoned
land that they had destroyed while
retreating Church Towers were our way
signs from one place to another and the
road they marked for us was rough the
roads and paths had vanished grass and
Thorn bushes had taken over leaks
purslane onions and garlic left in The
Gardens of the peasants were when they
could be found brought to me as the
choices Delicacies The Others May do
with mallow House Lake and cowbane Roots
we filled our hungry stomachs with these
and the spirit of life was revived in
our drained bodies finally on the eighth
day after leaving the forest we arrived
at the city of albayulia there we found
nothing saved the bone and skulls of the
Dead the destroyed and Broken Walls of
basilicas and palaces soiled by the
blood of an enormous number of
Christians ten miles from there next to
the forest was a village and here four
miles within the forest a marvelously
high mountain on the peak of it was a
rock a looming Crag where a great number
of men and women had taken Refuge
they received us with joy among tears
and inquired about the perils we had
passed through all of which we could not
tell them in a few words finally they
gave us black bread baked of flour and
the ground bark of oak trees and it
tasted sweeter than any seminal cake we
had ever eaten
although we often visited the formerly
inhabited Villages forced by need of
food it was never safe for us to come
down until the king returned to Hungary
with many companies of Warriors from the
maritime region assisted by the Knights
of Rhodes and the Lord's frankopan
having been previously informed by
hungarians of the retreat of the tartars
and so I have written all this to you
father without adding in anything false
so that you father who knows about the
felicitous turn of my fortune may know
as well about the true nature of my
Misfortune and danger
good health my father
remember to follow the link in the
description to dive into the chaotic
world of enlisted and its historically
accurate action clicking on the link
will also give you three days of Premium
Time and several orders for troops and
weapons
[Music]
foreign